melania trump not someone we typically
talk about but she gave her first
major interview since leaving the white
house as a failed first lady
this is an interview on fox news that i
have to tell you
north korean broadcasters who do north
korean state media
they would see this in blush and go this
is too fawning of an interview you have
to see this one of the big questions
from pete hegseth to melania was
given you how attractive you are and
successful in business isn't it biased
that you haven't been on the cover of
people magazine this is an interview
folks yes how did you put up with the
constant criticism the media
take uh vogue for example
five months into joe biden's president
joe biden's on the cover kamala harris
is on the cover before she's even sworn
in hillary clinton was on the cover when
she was first lady right michelle was on
the cover three times
yet
with your business background and your
fashion background and your beauty
never on the cover of vogue why i mean
is there a more possible question that
you could imagine that a question that's
more fawning than this double standard
they're biased
and
they have likes and dislikes and it's so
obvious and i think american people
and uh everyone see it
it was their decision and
i
have much more important things to do
and we don't know what those things are
but she apparently has more important
things to do
this is indistinguishable from a
scripted state media interview
um she said she she did enjoy living at
the white house i like washington dc
i know it operates completely different
than any other city
but
i really like it there and i enjoyed
living in the white house to be first
lady of the united states was my
greatest honor i think we achieved a lot
in the four years can you think of
anything melania achieved i can't think
of one single thing of trump
administration i
enjoyed taking care of the white house
it was
my home for a while
i understood it it is people's house
it was uh it was a privilege to live
there and maybe it'll be your home again
uh never say never right never say never
she may be back uh she took the fox and
friends interview as an opportunity to
promote her nfts which i still don't
even understand what they do or what
they're for and i kind of know a little
bit about this space and i have no clue
what it's about so you're using a new
technology to help
raise the profile and fund these
initiatives i have been working on my
nfd projects
since i left the white house my nfts
they are available on melaniatram.com
and
usmemorabilia.com and now we have a few
of the nfts that they are minting on it
it's a national park beautiful 3d
animated
pieces it's hard to imagine something
more inspirational than a 3d animated
melania nft isn't it and uh potus trump
there are pictures and animated videos
from our time in the white house and
especially the one that i created
for foster care month it's the rows the
metarose some of the proceeds of the
sales of nfts will go towards
education providing education
opportunities for foster care children
who are aging out of
foster system
yearly 20 000 children aging out of
foster care a year a year yes and now we
have four hundred seven thousand
children in foster care system in
america today so
i will what a hard-hitting interview
here and then lastly
she suggests her critics
maybe instead of criticizing her
um just help help foster kids okay well
people
i see always criticize me whatever i do
and i'm used to that
i move forward and i'm here to helping
people and that is the mission
and those people who criticize me
i would
encourage them to help in their own
community or maybe join my foster the
future initiative there you go so if you
were criticizing melania instead do
something to help the foster kids
what did we learn in this interview i
think we learned about the technique
of the completely meaningless
worthless
pointless
endless
softball interview that is within the
scope of what
pete hegseth on fox news can do
again you look at chinese state media
you look at saudi state media russia
today
you look at north koreans kcna
they would see this and go that oh man
that's a little too fawning even for us
we we at least pretend to ask a real
question pete hegseth didn't bizarre
stuff and uh there is melania in case
anybody was sort of anxiously waiting to
see what she had to say now
that she's out of the white house
i hope that it was satisfying to hear
from her
what if you could get through an entire
non-fiction book in just 15 minutes
blinkist takes top non-fiction books in
every genre boils them down into a text
or audio explainer that you can consume
in 15 minutes of course blinkist would
never replace reading real books in
their entirety but blinkist lets you
absorb the most important insights from
the non-fiction books you wouldn't
otherwise have time for i have a ton of
different ways i consume information and
blinkist is one of those and it's super
efficient i just used blinkist to listen
to the book toxic positivity
super interesting just about this like
happiness obsessed culture that now we
live in got through it in 15 minutes
with all of the key points blinkist also
takes tons of popular podcasts and
creates a 15-minute explainer for each
episode and blinkist really just
empowers you to grow by discovering new
ideas knowledge that will give you
valuable new perspectives about the
world go to blinkist dot com slash
pacman to try blinkist free for seven
days and you'll get twenty five percent
off a premium subscription that's just
six twenty five a month the link is down
below